[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم قصفت اذا طائرا النظام
السوري والطائرات الروسيه حي الوعر
المحاصر في مدينه حمص ما احدث دمارا واسعا
في الحي الذي تسيطر عليه المعارضه المسلحه
وقال ناشطون ان الطائرات الروسيه استخدمت
قنابل النابالم في قصف الحي ياتي ذلك في
او اثر اكتمال عمليه تهجير سكان مدينه
داريه بعد ان دمرتها طائرات النظام وروسيا
وسط مخاوف من عمليه تغيير ديموغرافي
وتطهير عرقي في سوريا نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش هو في محورين اولا ما هي دلالات
تصعيد النظام السوري وحليفه الروسي
عمليه التدمير والتهجير الممنهجه في
سوريا وكيف يمكن فهم الصمت الامريكي ازاءه
تلك الانتهاكات وخاصه استخدام النابالم
وعمليات
التهجير لا يكشف النظام السوري وحليفه
الروسي عن اهدافه الخفيه بالضبط لكنهما
ثفان استخدام الاسلحه المحرمه دوليا ضد
مسلحي المعارضه والمدنيين العزل الهدف
فيما يبدو هو تحقيق اكبر قدر من الرعب
لاجبار المدنيين في مناطق محيط دمشق وحدود
لبنان على الرحيل وياتي ذلك في اطار ما
يعتبر سياسه ممنهجه لتطهير عرقي يعتمد
اسلوب الحصار والتدمير
والتهجير المفارقه ان كل ذلك يعتبر جرائم
حرب وفق القانون الدولي لكنه يحدث ايضا
وسط صمت عالمي وامريكي بصفه خاصه نتابع
تقرير زياد بركات ثم نفتح النقاش مع
ضيوفنا لم تذكر المواقع التي نشرت صور هذا
الطفل اسمه تركته يرتجف امام العالم عاريا
ومن دون اسم لكن له اسما وابا واما في حي
الوعر سواهما يعرفان ربما لماذا ارتجف
كثيرا لانه ببساطه كان ضحيه قصف بالنا
بالم الذي يعتبر استخدامه ضد المدنيين
جريمه حرب منذ عام
1980 وهو لمن لا يعرف سلاح انتج في
المختبرات الامريكيه واستخدم في الحرب على
فيتنام وتكمن خطورته في انه سائل هلامي
قابل للاشتعال السريع ويلتصق بالجلد فور
القائه على ضحايا مخلفا الاما مبرحه قد
تدمر الجهاز العصبي للبالغين فكيف
بالاطفال ما يجعلهم يرتجفون فيقوم البعض
بدهن اجسادهم بالطين لامتصاص تاثيرات
النابالم المدمره لقد خبر طفل حي الوعر كل
هذا دفعه واحده على جسده الغض فارتجف وظل
يرتجف في صوره التي انتشرت على مواقع
التواصل
الاجتماعي هنا حي الوعر اخر معاقل
المعارضه في حمص لقد جاء دوره بعد داريا
اما استراتيجيه النظام هنا فنفسها احكام
الحصار عليه وهو ما يحدث بشكل مستمر منذ
اكتوبر عام
2013 ولاحقا تكثيف القصف عليه لاجبار
المدنيين والمعارضه على صفقه اخلاء يقول
كثيرون انها تطهير عرقي في
حقيقتها حدث هذا في بقيه احياء حمص قبل
نحو عامين يخرجون وقد انتصروا اخلاقيا
لكنهم يعرفون وهم يتوجهون الى الشمال
وخصوصا ادلب ان النظام يريد مناطق صافيه
طائفيا تتصل بلبنان وخصوصا المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها حزب الله
واذا عطف هذا على ما حدث في صفقه الزبداني
كفري الفوعه فان النظام السوري ومستشاريه
الايرانيين يواصلون خطه ما تسمى سوريا
المفيده وتلك تتطلب خلق مناطق تابعه تماما
للنظام اما بتصفيات طائفيه لا تخفى او
بتغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في بعض
المناطق وثمه ما يتردد عن مئات الايرانيين
الذين جرى توطينهم وهناك امثالهم من
العراقيين الذين يستعدون لدخول داريا
والاستقرار
فيها على من ينتصر هؤلاء لا احد ينتصر على
شعبه في نهايه المطاف كما يقول معارضو
الاسد وحدهم الطغاه من يتوهم
هذا
للمناقشه موضوع حلقتنا هذا ينضم الينا من
لندن بسام جعاره الكاتب والاعلامي السوري
المعارض
وينضم الينا ايضا من اتلانتا بولايه
جورجيا الامريكيه ينضم الينا لاري كورب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي نرحب
بضيفي وابدا معك استاذ بسام جعار في لندن
واضح ان صوره هذا الطفل يعني لو كان
للعالم ضمير لكانت كفيله بانهاء حروب
وصراعات وهزت الراي العام العالمي يعني
استخدام اسلحه محرمه دوليا مثل ان نا
بالالم في حق سكان حي ال الوعر تطرح اسئله
حول في اي سياق يمكن فهم استخدام او
استمرار سوريا او النظام
السوري في استخدام الاسلحه المحرمه دوليا
بهذا الشكل في حي الوعر وفي
غيره يعني اسمحي لي ذكر ان السيد كيري
تحدث منذ يومين عن الطفل عمران عمران حلب
وقال ان صوره الطفل تدفعنا الى البحث عن
حل سياسي ثم قال ايضا ان النظام لا يتوقف
عن قدم الاراضي والمساحات وما يفعله يؤكد
بانه ما زال يتبع الحل العسكري اللي بدي
اقول بكل وضوح كل هذه الجرائم التي ترتكب
بسوريا منذ خمس سنوات تتم برعايه واشراف
امريكي واضح انا لا اتهم امريكا بالصمت بل
اقول انها متواطئه وانها سبب كل ما يجري
للشعب السوري اتحدث عن امريكا قبل ان
اتحدث عن الاجرام الروسي عن الاجرام
الايراني بدي اذكر فقط منذ ايام عندما
حاول النظام حسم معركه الحسكه صدر قرار او
بيان من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه يقول انه
اذا حلقت طائره واحده للنظام في سماء
الحسكه فسوف يتم اسقاطها ولكن عندما يتعلق
الامر بالشعب السوري عندما يقصف بعد تهديد
اوباما يشن تشن عليه 136 هجمه بالكيماوي
منذ عام 13 حتى الان وتصمت امريكا فهذا
يعني ان هناك ضوءا اخضر امريكيا بقصف وقتل
الشعب السوري عندما يقول كيري منذ يومين
وتقول الخارجيه الامريكيه والبيت الابيض
انه لن يكون هناك مناطق امنه فهذا يعني
منح ضوء اخضر لنظام لكي يقتل الناس بكل
انواع الاستحام ليس النابان فقط بل
استخدموا كل انواع الاسلحه المحرمه دوليا
القنابل العنقوديه الفراغيه استخدمت روسيا
القنبله الحراريه وهي قنبله نوويه صغيره
لم يتركوا سلاحا الا واستخدموه اما مساله
المستوطنات فهذه قصه قديمه تعود الى منتصف
الستينات عندما بدا النظام باقامه
مستوطنات طائفيه في مدينه دمشق في عشر
الورر في المسجد ست
في قدسيه في بقيه المناطق وعندما بدات
الثوره السوريه اتبعوا او رسموا مخطط
للتهجير الطائفي هذا الامر لا يتعلق
بتطهير عرقي بل اقول بكل وضوح هي عمليه
تطهير طائفي تمتد من دمشق الى حمص بدات
بالقصير ولم تنتهي في داريا ولن تتوقف عند
ما يجري الان في حمص خليني اقول بكل وضوح
او ذكر بما قاله لافروف منذ ايام منذ
اسبوعين قال حرفيا وعلى المكشوف ان الحرب
في سوريا او الحل يتطلب تحقيق التوازن
الديني ماذا يعني ذلك يعني تهجير 16 17
مليون سوري او قتل لتحقيق هذا التوازن بين
حوالي 18 مليون سني وحوالي خمسه من ابناء
الاقليات خليني نذكر امريكا تمنع اقامه
منطقه امنه تمنع حص سوار على مضادات
طائرات التي تمنع عمليات القتل العشوائي
عندما جاءت روسيا الى سوريه قالت ان مهمه
القوات الروسيه سوف تمتد بين شهر وثلاثه
اشهر والان انتهى الشهر الحادي عشر ولم
تفلح روسيا في الحل العسكري فالتفتوا الى
قتل المدنيين فقط لاجبار الشعب السوري على
الركوع طي انتقل دعني انتقل الى نعم سنذكر
معنا وقت تفضل جمله واحده فقط تفضل منذ
يومين كان كان كيري يقول انه سيطلب من
لافروف وقف القصف الجوي لقوات النظام وبعد
انتهاء المباحثات قال انه فشل في اقناع
الروس طيب هذا الموقف يبدو غريبا سيد لاري
كورب هذا الصمط الامريكي وايضا الدولي
والمنظمات الدوليه ايضا وعلى راسها الامم
المتحده يعني ت حدث عن استخدام اسلحه
محرمه دوليا عن قنابل عنقوديه عن السلاح
الكيميائي عن قنابل النابالم الان وانت
شاهدت بنفسك قبل قليل صوره الطفل الذي
يرتجف جراء تاثره بقصف بقنابل النابالم
المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه والانسانيه والسياسيه
التي تتحملها امريكا والمجتمع الدولي اذاء
هذه الصور الماساويه
لسوريين يتعرضون لكل هذا ما
هي
حسنا لا شك في ان المجتمع الدولي ينبغي ان
يكون غاضبا وان يتصرف ضد من يستخدمون هذه
الاسلحه الممنوعه
دولي الروس قالوا وهذا خطا انهم لا
يستخدمون الاسلحه الكيميائيه بينما نحن
نعرف انهم يفعلون ذلك لسوء الحظ ان الروس
لدي
فيتو في مجلس الامن يمكنهم ان يمنعوا
اتخاذ اي قرار ضدهم والمجتمع الدولي لا
ينبغي ان يغمض عينيه عن ذلك لكن الفكره في
الولايات المتحده يمكنها ان تدخل وتحل هذه
المشكله حتى لو ان اقوياء فحنا لسنا بهذه
القوه ومن
المستحيل لنا ان نفعل ذلك دون ان نخلق
المزيد من مشكل لان تنظيم الدوله يمكن ان
يقول ان الغرب بقياده الولايات المتحده هو
الذي
يحاربهم ولا شك في اننا ينبغي
علينا ان يكون هناك وقف مؤقت لاق النار
للسماح للناس من الخروج ولا شك في انه
ينبغي ان نركز على محاربه تنظيم الدوله
وان يكون هناك حكومه انتقاليه في سوريا
لكن ذلك يسهل قوله ولكن تطبيقه صعب جدا
لان الايرانيين يريدون ان والروس يحافظوا
على الاسد في الحكم
والاتراك يتدخلون الان وهم مشغولون ايضا
بما يقوم به الاكراد ويستخدمون الاكراد
ليحاربوا تنظيم الدوله من سوء الحظ ليس
هناك حل بسيط وسهل لهذه الماساه
الانسانيه كما انه انه حدث يذكرنا بما حدث
في رواندا قبل 20 و عشر سنوات طيب استاذ
بسام جعاره الى اي مدى تبدو هذه التبريرات
التي قدمها الان لاري كورب بخصوص هذا
العجز الامريكي والدولي من ان روسيا لديها
الفيتو في مجلس الامن من ان العالم مشغول
بمحاربه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وما الى
ذلك من العناصر التي قدمها الان لاري كورب
في تبرير كل هذا الصمت الدولي والعجز
الدولي والامريكي في امام هذه الماسي التي
تحدث في
سوريا دعيني اقول بوضوح لضيفك اولا هذا
التواطؤ الامريكي او الاجرام الامريكي بحق
الشعب السوري بدا قبل ان يظهر تنظيم
الدوله في سوريا عندما دخل شبابنا باتجاه
الساحل ووصلوا الى مشارف اللاذقيه ظهر
الفيتو الامريكي وضغط على الاشقاء لسحب
هؤلاء من معركه الساحل وكلنا يعرف ان
النظام لا يمكن ان يسقط الا في مكانين اما
في الساحل او في دمشق ايضا عندما وصل ثوار
درعا الى مشارف دمشق الى الكسوه تحديدا
سارعت امريكا واوقفت تقدم هؤلاء اعادتهم
الى درعا وعندما حاولوا مساعده داريه
انقاذ داريه كان الفيتو الامريكي بالمرصاد
بل وصل الامر الى حد تهديد التهديد بقصف
القوات التي تتقدم باتجاه دمشق ومنع وقاده
الفصائل من التقدم منعوا السلاح منعوا كل
شيء انا اعطي مثال الحسكه منذ اسبوعين
لماذا تظهر امريكا قويه عندما لا يتعلق
الامر بالشعب السوري عندما هددوا النظام
باسقاط طائراته لماذا يهددون النظام
باسقاط طائراته عندما يخصف داريه عندما
يخصف الوعر عندما يدمر حلب تدمير منهجي
ايضا لماذا منع وصول المساعدات الى درئ
لماذا يصرون الان على دخول المساعدات من
طريق الكاستيلو لكي يتمكن النظام من
السيطره على الطريق ولا تدخل المساعدات عن
طريق الراموس لماذا تحولت الامم المتحده
الى شريك في عمليه في عمليه التطهير
العرقي طيب هذا التطيير العرقي كما تسميه
ما حجم التغيير سوف نتحدث طبعا بعد الفاصل
عن حجم التغيير الذي يحدثه
هذا التطهير هذا التهجير هذا التدمير لهذه
المناطق المستهدفه على مستوى تغيير
الخارطه الديموغرافيه في اتجاه ما يمكن
تسميته بالخطه ب بالنسبه للنظام السوري
وهو سوريا المفيده او سوريا الصافيه
مذهبيا سوف نناقش ذلك بعد الفاصل لا
تذهبوا
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم كم من جديد
الى هذه الحلقه ونرحب بكم و بضيوفنا ضيفين
من جديد ايضا اتحول اليك لاري كرب يعني
كما قال بسم جعاره قبل الفاصل عمليه
التدمير الممنهج والتهجير الممنهج ل لسكان
هذه المناطق يعني يعتبر التهجير مثله مثل
النبال مثل يعني الكيميائي هو ايضا جريمه
حرب وتتم تحت اعين العالم حتى لا نقول
برعايه دوليه او برعايه الامم المتحده
التي سكتت قبل ايام عن تهجير سكان
داريا هل امريكا
ومع المجتمع الدولي يمكن ان نقول انها
متواطئه
وشريكه في في هذه في عمليه التصفيه
العرقيه لسكان هذه
المناطق
وتهجيرهم
الى ان تتوفر اعتذر لمقاطعك استاذ لار كور
الى ان تتوفر الترجمه باللغه العربيه سوف
اعود الى بسام جعاره ثم اعود اليك الى حين
توفر الترجمه استاذ بم تتحدث اذا عن هذا
الموضوع عن موضوع التهجير والتدمير
الممنهج اذا هناك خطه جاهزه لتصفيه او
لخلق خارطه ديموغرافيه جديده من اجل تصفيه
المنطقه مذهبيا هذا ما كنت تقوله
تفضل اسمعي لي وضح اكثر يعني حتى لا تكون
هناك حجه وحديث عن وجود ثوار في داريا
دعيني اذكر بما جرى قبل عام في منطقه مزه
بساتين في دمشق عندما جرى اخلاء الاف
السكان على ترك منازلهم وت تهجيرهم منها
بدون حرب لم يكن هناك اي اي سائر في تلك
المنطقه ثم جاءت شركات ايرانيه دمرت
المنطقه بكامله بكامله وتعيد بناءها الان
بمعنى اخر كما قلت هناك عمل ممنهج اقامه
حزام من المستوطنات الطائفيه تمتد من دمشق
الى حمص وجلب ملايين سكان في تشرين الثاني
القادم هناك اعياد دينيه في العراق وطلبت
ايران من الحكومه العراقيه اعفاء
الايرانيين من تاشيره الدخول
وسيتدبر في العام الفائت ومعظم هؤلاء
سيدخلون الى سوريا ليقيموا في هذه المناطق
هم يعتقدون انهم يحققون توازن بادخال
مليون او اكثر من الافغان من الايرانيين
من العراقيين من اللبنانيين وهذا العمل لم
يتوقف طيله الفتره الماضيه امام مراه
ومشهد العالم ماذا تقول امريكا هناك طيب
ماذا تقول امريكا د دعنا نقل هذا السؤال
ماذا تقول امريكا لان الترجمه توفرت الان
سيد لاريك كور بالفعل يعني ماذا تقول
امريكا امام كل هذا لماذا خلينا نتحدث بال
الواقع الملموس لماذا ترفض على سبيل
المثال امريكا ان تقام منطقه امنه هذا
مثال من الامثله الكثيره عن الموقف
الامريكي وتقاعسه في سوريا
تفضل اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده في الاساس
لو كان هناك مناطق امنه كيف يمكن ان نضمن
ان يدخل اليها ليسوا من تنظيم الدوله او
من النسره من السهل قول ذلك لكن تطبيقه
صعب في ليبيا كنا هناك ل التخلص من
ديكتاتور والوضع هناك
اصبح اكثر صعوبه واسوا بكثير اذا الامور
من السهل قولها لكن التطبيق صعب سيحتاج
100 الا جندي امريكي لضمان ان يكون هناك
مناطق امنه وتتم ادارتها
بشكل جيد ولا يتسرب
اليها الاجرامي مثل النسره وتنظيم
الدوله وهذا هو الوضع الذي ينبغي ان
نتعامل معه اذا وضعت 100 الا من الجنود
الامريكيين فمن السهل على تنظيم الدوله ان
يقول ان الغرب هو الذي يقوم بالحرب لكن
سيد لاري كورب لو عدنا يعني
ب الذاكره الجماعيه الى مثلا حرب فيتنام
كلنا نتذكر ان ما اوقف حرب فيتنام هو تلك
الصور المروعه لضحايا استخدام الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه للاسلحه المحرمه دوليا
في تلك الفتره ضد الفيتناميين مثل النبال
يعني هذه مشاهد لا تقل خطوره عما حدث لل
الفيتناميين ما الذي يجعل الحرب اذا لا
تتوقف في سوريا كما توقفت في فيتنام على
يد
الامريكيين من سوء الحظ ان الحرب في
فيتنام لم
تتوقف بعد توقفت بعد سبع سنوات كامله بعد
تلك
الصور التي راينا فيها الناس محروقين
بنبال نعم بدا ذلك يغير الراي العام
ضد الحرب هناك لكن الكثير من الامريكيين
كانوا يعتقدون انها انها صراع ضد الشيوعين
السوفيتيين كان هناك اثر ولكن تطلب الامر
وقتا
طويلا قبل ان تتغير
السياسه و ليس قبل عام 75 تلك البنت التي
كانت في عام 65 وليس
يبدو عدد السنوات غير دقيق سيد لاري كورب
لم تستمر سبع سنوات لكن لن لن نخوض في كل
هذه التفاصيل نعود الى موضوعنا موضوع
سوريا مع بسام جعاره الان هذا المخطط الذي
يسعى اليه النظام السوري مع حلفه الروسي
يبدو انه بالنسبه للنظام يؤتي اكله ماذا
بالنسبه للم المعارضه ما المطلوب ما
البدائل يعني فقط اسمحي لي قبل ما ادخل
بهذه النقطه خليني نذكر ضيفك الامريكي ان
هناك قرار مجلس الامن يمنع على ايران
ارسال قوات هو يتحدث عن جبهه النصره وعن
داعش لا يتحدث عن الحرج الثوري الايراني
المصنف ارهابيا ولا عن حزب الله ولا يقول
ان الطائرات الامريكيه تحمي قاسم سليماني
في العراق الامريكيون مجرمون هم في اي
محكمه دوليه يمكن ان نحاكم اوباما وكيري
والاداره الامريكيه كشريك في عمليات
الاجرام التي تتم بحق الشعب السوري نحن لا
نتحدث عن تقصير نتحدث عن اجرام امريكي
خلال لحظات استطاعوا اقامه منطقه حظر جوي
في الحسكه منذ ايام والجميع يعرف ذلك
وضيفك بيعرف ان هناك مئات المقاتلين
الامريكان في الحسكه قرب تنظيم الدوله
والامر لا يعني لم يضطرهم لارسال عشره
الالاف نحن لا نريد تدخلا عسكريا امريكيا
طلبت تركيا اقامه منطقه حظر جوي قالت انها
تتولاها وقالت انها تستطيع تامين منطقه
امنه ودائما هناك رفض امريكي امريكا ت موا
معرو بسام جعار قد تبدو الان الظروف
مواتيه اكثر بالنسبه لتركيا لاقامه
المنطقه
الامنه لا تستطيع تركيا بدون موافقه من
حلف النيتو هي تعرف تماما انها مستهدفه من
ايران ومن روسيا ومن الجميع والتامر
الامريكي على تركيا كان اكبر من التامر
الروسي وكلنا يعرف ان تركيا كانت شريك في
الانقلاب العسكري وعندما فشل اصيبت بصب
هذا الامر يعرفه
الجميع امريكا اكيد امريكا طبعا امريكا
اداره اوباما كانت تراهن على التغيير ليس
في تركيا فقط التغيير في سوريا اذا
استطاعت انجاح الانقلاب العسكري في تركيا
ولذلك كنا نقول ان المعركه واحده خليني
اقول بكل وضوح امريكا تتحدث الان تقول
انها لا تريد معاقبه النظام على الكيماوي
بل تريد ل ربما في اقل من دقيقه ربما هناك
تغير طفيف في الموقف الامريكي فيما يتعلق
بكل هذه المسائل لمس من خلال التعامل مثلا
مع الميليشيات الكرديه في اعقاب التدخل
العسكري التركي في سوريا مؤخرا الا يعد
هذا مثلا مؤشر يعني تفاؤل في تغير الموقف
الامريكي ابدا على الاطلاق خشيه امريكا ان
تندفع تركيا باتجاه روسيا خشيت على
مصالحها خشيت من تحالف ايراني روسي يخرج
امريكا من المنطقه فبدا الكذب وبدا
الاعتذار وجاء بايدن الى تركيا ليعتذر بعد
اكثر من شهر ونص من محاوله الانقلاب هذا
اللعب الامريكي مكشوف ونحن نقول حتى الان
لا يستطيع الاكراد تفجير اي هدف في تركيا
الا بموافقه امريكيه شكرا شكرا لك بسام
جعار الكاتب والاعلامي السوري المعارض كنت
معنا من لندن وشكرا للاري كورب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق وكبير الباحثين في
مركز التقدم الامريكي كنت معنا من جورجيا
شكرا جزيلا لكما وشكرا لمشاهدينا على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد اطيب المنى
[موسيقى]
واللقاء
ه